Ja und jetzt wie schaut es jetzt aus leute
Jetzt ist besser wieder okay
Okay
F5 jetzt geht es wieder. Oh man, alter, was ist das gewesen?
Ich glaube es liegt nicht mal an Vodafone, sondern einer der Twitch-Server in Frankfurt ist abgeschissen
Weil ich habe jetzt einfach den Server gewechselt und jetzt gibt es keinerlei Lags
Bin von Frankfurt 5 auf Frankfurt 2, Twitch-Server
Ich glaube diesmal kann Vodafone nichts dafür. Ich glaube wirklich, dass der Server von Twitch verreckt ist gerade
AWS kaputt
oder AWS
Wieder die richtig krassen leute zu sagen
Ja, ich glaube Twitch hat wieder Probleme
Vodafone Emote wäre nice, wir haben irgendwo ein Vodafone Bild, wir haben das
Moment, es gibt
Das ist ja mega, da muss ich mal eins hinzufügen, Sekunde, da muss ich mal das passende hinzufügen
Chat, welches, welches wollen wir davon hinzufügen?
Ihr könnt es euch aussuchen. Also ich persönlich finde das hier ja nicht verkehrt
Aber die zwei sind auch cool, das ist auch nice
Das ist auch cool, viels Vodafone man, das ist ja geil
Ich glaube viels Vodafone man wird's
Perfekt, es läuft bei allen schon wieder
Okay, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir haben angefangen uns das Video anzuschauen hier, das ist das da
Ich spule mal ein bisschen zurück, dass wir alles mitgekriegt haben. So, also
Erstes mal macOS, komme ich damit zurecht, da sind wir stehen geblieben.
Ich will hier drauf kommen, ich will die doch nicht löschen, die Diskette
Naja, mein Apple Trauma hat sich dann über die Jahre etwas aufgelöst
Ich hatte dann irgendwann ein iPad, was ich sehr ins Herz geschlossen habe
Und mir sogar irgendwann für diesen Kanal ja ein iPhone 13 Pro als immer
Also wie gesagt, ich habe auch ein iPhone, ein iPad, ich mag das Apple Ökosystem jetzt zwar nicht so extrem
Da ich sage, oh ich will alles Apple-mäßige haben, mir geht das auch regelmäßig auf den Kicks
Aber gerade wenn wieder so der Apple-Way der einzige ist, der funktioniert, ja
Aber insgesamt muss ich sagen, gerade was iPads angeht, finde ich die schon angenehmer als Android-Tablets
Und ich habe mich jetzt seit Jahren ans iPhone gewöhnt, ich gehe davon aus, im mobilen Sektor werde ich dem iPhone und dem iPad da auch treu bleiben
Aber nicht, dass jemand sagt, ich hätte das nicht ausprobiert, ich habe auch Android-Tablets am Start
Ich denke, man sollte einfach das benutzen, was sich für den jeweiligen Anwendungszweck gut eignet
Und gerade was Automatisierung angeht, ja und so als Home-Assistant-Dashboard im Flur und sowas, da sind Android-Tablets natürlich nice
Dabei, Videokamera angeschafft, ich war davor eher so der Android-Typ, aber die Videoqualität des iPhones hat mich dann ziemlich schnell überzeugt
Ja, und jetzt ein macOS-Gerät, wow, fremdartige Welten
Ich muss allerdings auch zugeben, dass es mich wirklich genervt hat, dass ich mich mit eigentlich allen relevanten mobilen und Desktop-Betriebssystemen
einigermaßen gut auskenne, aber halt überhaupt nicht mit macOS
Und mein Selbstverständnis als Tech-Journalist ist schon so, dass ich so unabhängig und neutral wie möglich sein will
und mit diesen komischen Fanboy- und Girl-Konflikten nichts zu tun haben will
Und wie kann ich denn bitte wissen, dass mir, sagen wir mal, Linux am besten gefällt, wenn ich die Alternativen gar nicht kenne
Also macOS stand eh auf meiner To-Do-Liste, auch wenn ich zugegebenermaßen ein bisschen Angst davor hatte
Ja, und nun brauchte ich einen neuen Bürorechner, ein Notebook sollte es sein, da ich viel zwischen irgendwelchen Drehorten hin- und herrenne
und da gerne mein Zeug dabei habe
An meinen Hauptarbeitsplätzen wollte ich einen großen Monitor und eine richtige Tastatur benutzen
Und um ehrlich zu sein, hatte ich mit Windows...
Da kann er sich ja den Monitorhalter für 1000 Euro kaufen
...Dockingstation, häufiger mal Probleme, irgendwelches Auflösungsgefrückel, dass er sich das nicht richtig gemerkt hat, wie ich das eingestellt habe
Kennt ihr noch diesen Monitorhalter für 1000 Euro?
Ja, fand ich alles nicht so smooth
Die Apple-Leute im Team schwärmten da aber immer von, wie einfach das alles mit macOS klappt
Was dann letztendlich den Ausschlag gegeben hat, war eine einzige Software, Whisper von OpenAI, die ich regelmäßig benutze, um Texttranskriptionen unserer Videos vorzubereiten
für die YouTube-Untertitel zum Beispiel
Da wirft man einfach eine Audiodatei drauf und dann kommt da hinten fast veröffentlichungsfähiger Text raus
Ja, und unter Windows und Linux läuft das nur mit einer richtig fetten Grafikkarte mit mindestens 10 Gigabyte Videospeicher
Und außerdem habe ich noch keine richtige grafische Benutzauberfläche dafür gefunden, also alles so Kommandozeile
Unter macOS dagegen gibt es ein super nice bedienendes grafisches Tool, das auch noch sehr schnell auf Apple-Silicon-Hardware läuft
Entschieden habe ich mich letztendlich für einen MacBook Air mit M.2 und 24 Gigabyte RAM in Midnight
Die lassen sich dort bestimmt auch Speicherplatz wieder fürstlich bezahlen, oder?
Also, dieses nette Blau-Schwarz, das fand ich ziemlich schön und das ist auch neutraler, finde ich, als dieses Standard-Silber, das ich irgendwie sofort mit MacBooks assoziiere
Ja, dann los geht's, USB-C-Kabel vom Monitor rein, äh, ja, geht
Hä, das war jetzt schon direkt...
Warte mal, mein Monitor hat gar keinen USB-C-Anschluss
Da wird vom Monitor halt direkt über Power Delivery mit Strom versorgt, Maus und Tastatur stecken einfach per USB im Monitor
Ja, und dann konnte man damit arbeiten
Ja, also ich weiß, das können aktuelle Windows-Notebooks auch und das ist mit Windows 11 auch deutlich besser geworden
Aber mit macOS funktioniert dieses ganze Docking-Station-Ding meiner Meinung nach noch ein kleines bisschen geschmeidiger
Was ich nun aber erstmal herausfinden musste, wie installiert man eigentlich Software auf so einem Apple?
Das weiß ich, das weiß ich, okay
Entweder über den App-Store oder man lädt sich ein Package runter und track und drop das Package auf so einen Installer-Icon
Das hab ich auch schon mal gemacht
Das ist eines meiner wenigen macOS-Erfahrungen
Mal App-Store ausprobiert, hier unten in der Task-Leiste
Okay, da hab ich dann schon direkt mal die Whisper-Software gefunden und installiert
Kannst du mal ein Video machen, Windows 10 vs. Windows 11?
Naja, ich hab ja schon mal ähnliche, ich hab ja schon ein paar Windows 11...
Ich reg mich drüber auf, Videos gemacht, so viel hatte ich ja noch nicht getan, also...
Ich verwende Windows 11 ja eigentlich auch nicht, weil ich scharf auf Windows 11 bin
Sondern weil Windows 11 das einzige OS ist
Zumindest Microsoft-Windows-mäßig, was meine CPU ordentlich unterstützt
Die gibt's ja nicht, dafür gibt's Launchpad
Das zeigt alle installierten Programme an
Ja, okay, da ist auch Whisper
Oder man kann auch den Finder verwenden
Das ist quasi der Datei-Browser aka. Explorer in Windows
Und da finden sich die installierten Programme ja eigentlich ganz logisch im Ordner Programme
Das benutze ich aber nicht, sondern ich finde Spotlight viel eleganter
Einfach die Command-Taste plus Leertaste, dann geht Spotlight auf
Das ist sozusagen so ein kombinierter Launcher plus geräteübergreifender Suchfunktion
Da gebe ich dann WH ein und schon ergänzt Spotlight zu Whisper
Das ist ganz nice, ich meine ich hab ja unter Linux was ähnliches
Wenn auch nicht so optisch so hübsch und wahrscheinlich auch nicht so gut integriert mit dem OS
Wie das unter Mac der Fall ist
Ja, Windows kannst du komplett knicken
Was das Startmenü angeht
Voll und komplett für'n Arsch, die Suche ist auch für'n Arsch
Noch schlimmer, dass man hier immer irgendwas eingibt
Manchmal irgendwelche komischen Web-Ergebnisse bekommt
Und sowas ganz Paint-Champig
So, ich hab ja auch hier sowas zum starten
Guck, hier kann ich auch eins sagen, Firefox oder Tuner für File-Manager oder sowas
Also sowas hier geht auch
Und noch besser, ich kann sogar Emojis durchsuchen
Keckl, ah ne, gibt's ja nicht
Was weiß ich, Hartz
Dann hab ich noch meinen durchsuchbaren Clipboard-Manager und ein paar Skripts zum Ausführen
Find ich auch ganz nice
Man kann das auch kombinieren
Man könnte beispielsweise auch eine Suche machen über alles hier unten drunter
Will ich aber gar nicht
Ich find das eigentlich ganz gut, wenn das ein bisschen eingeschränkt ist
Ja, also wenn ich irgendwas Grafisches starten muss, mach ich das eigentlich immer darüber
Ja, zum Beispiel wenn ich sag hier, ich will einen Raspberry Pi Imager
Ja, man findet das auch so, man muss sich Imager suchen
Also wenn ich Raspberry Pi Imager starten will, kann ich das auch hier mitmachen
Also das find ich ganz nice
Das ist bei mir übrigens nicht auf Windows-Taste Space, beziehungsweise Control-Space, wie unter Mac
Sondern ich hab das auf Windows-Taste D
Und ich hab Windows-Taste P für Copy-Paste Clipboard-Manager
Obwohl es eigentlich das gleiche Programm ist
Ich kann auch dazwischen umschalten
Also hier Firefox starten
Geht dann halt auch so relativ schnell
Terminal hab ich als Shortcut auf Windows-Taste Enter
Und hier kann man z.B. Studio Code aufmachen
Dann kann man hier rüberswitchen, kann Rider aufmachen und so
Da hat man alles
Hier oben ist übrigens meine CPU-Auslastung
War grad mit 8 Kerne voll
Ups, was hab ich jetzt gemacht?
Jetzt hab ich das in Fullscreen geschaltet und ich weiß nicht wie
Ja, okay
Was macht eigentlich die JetBrains-Toolbox? Gibt's da wieder neue Sachen?
Check for Updates
Keine Updates, okay
Ja, so sieht das aus
So, gucken wir mal weiter, wie es mit seiner macOS-Journey ausschaut
Am Starte, super
So, dass über Tastatur zu bedienen, also über die Schnellsuche, ist auch bei Windows und Linux meine favorisierte Programm-Startart
Nur, dass man halt unter Windows und oft auch unter Linux einfach nur die Command-Taste drücken muss
Bei macOS ist das halt Command plus Space, um diese Suche aufzurufen
Gut, das hat sich schnell eingespeichert, dass man die Leertaste noch braucht
Ich muss auch sagen, dass Spotlight etwas besser funktioniert als die Suchfunktion von Windows
Ich find Spotlight nämlich übersichtlicher und die findet auch relevantere Sachen für mich
Ja gut, die Windows-Suche ist halt komplett lost
Was mein Profi unter Linux nicht kann, ist tatsächlich Context, also Content von Files, so Context-basiert zu durchsuchen
Ehrlich gesagt, keine Ahnung, ob das mir viel bringen würde
Ist jetzt selten, dass ich mir denke, oh hier wär jetzt cool, wenn ich direkt nach Dateienhalten suchen kann
Wenn ich was suche, dann mach ich einfach Find oder Grab auf der Kommandozeile
Aber gut, wenn es dann um sowas wie Kalender-Einträge und so geht, ok, lass ich mir gefallen, dass das ganz cool ist
Da kommst du mit Grab halt nicht weiter
Angenommen, du hast irgendwie deinen Thunderbird oder deinen Web-Outlook oder was auch immer
Dann wäre so eine Integration ganz gut
Wobei die Integration wahrscheinlich auch nur gut funktioniert, wenn du das macOS eigene E-Mail-Programm
Die haben ganz gute Calendarf-Unterstützung, was leider unter Windows ein bisschen krankt
Unter Linux auch nicht
Ja, na gut
Kalender, Fotos und so weiter, das ist ganz cool
So, aber jetzt mal etwas strukturierter alles
Hier kommen jetzt 4 positive Überraschungen und dann nochmal 4 negative
Positive Überraschung Nummer 1, Performance und Effizienz
Das hat natürlich nicht direkt mit dem Betriebssystem zu tun, aber ich bin wirklich von der hohen Schwuppdizipität meines Macbooks überrascht
Das ist auch was, ich habe nicht oft was mit Mac gemacht, aber immer wenn ich da mal dran gegangen bin
Das hat sich äußerst responsive alles angefühlt und das war noch zu Zeiten vor M2 und M1
Ist auf dem iPad und auf dem iPhone ähnlich, aber das ist nochmal ein anderes Level
Also ich hatte noch Intel-basierte Macs, wo ich ab und zu mal dran gegangen bin
Das hat sich da auch schon alles sehr sehr responsive angefühlt
Alles geht schnell, ich habe mir lediglich beim Berechnen von KI-Bildern mit Stable Diffusion gewünscht, dass der Rechner ein bisschen mehr Wumms hätte
Bei wirklich allen anderen Aufgaben kam mir die Reaktionsgeschwindigkeit sogar schneller vor als mit meiner fetten Windows-Desktop-Maschine
Dass das mit einem passiv gekühlten Laptop möglich ist, hätte ich noch vor ein paar Jahren nicht für möglich gehalten
Das krasse dabei ist, das Ding wird nicht mal heiß und der Akku hält ewig
Apple-Silicon mit ARM-Architektur ist wirklich ein Sprung nach vorne, vor allem wenn man die Leistung pro Watt betrachtet
Ich bin wirklich gespannt, wie das weitergeht mit ARM vs. Vintel x86
Wir haben übrigens schon mal ein Video dazu gemacht, das ist hier oben
Positive Überraschung Nummer 2
Integration von iPhone und iPad
Vermutlich sind da alle von erschreckt worden, die zum ersten Mal macOS mit dem iPhone benutzt haben
Wenn jemand anruft, klingelt der Computer und man erschreckt sich
Da kommt dann so ein Popup oben rechts und man kann den Anruf direkt auf dem Rechner annehmen
Auch wenn das Telefon im ganz anderen Raum ist
Für mich ist das super, weil ich das Telefon meistens lautlos habe und dann nicht mitbekomme, wenn jemand anruft, wenn ich vorm Rechner sitze
Richtig nett ist auch, dass macOS die per SMS aufs iPhone geschickten 2-Faktor-Codes automatisch bereitstellt
Wenn man auf dem iPhone Einstellung Nachrichten SMS Weiterleitung aktiviert hat, füllt der Browser direkt beim Einloggen auf dem Rechner den 2-Faktor-Code aus
Außerdem geht sogar Copy-Paste Hardware übergreifend, ich kann also einen Text oder Bild auf dem Rechner kopieren
Wobei man sich fragt, hebt man damit nicht 2-Faktor so ein bisschen aus?
Deshalb muss ich mir das nochmal kurz angucken
Richtig nett ist auch, dass macOS die per SMS aufs iPhone geschickten 2-Faktor-Codes automatisch bereitstellt
Wenn man auf dem iPhone Einstellung Nachrichten SMS Weiterleitung aktiviert hat, füllt der Browser direkt beim Einloggen auf dem Rechner den 2-Faktor-Code aus
Na gut, damit hebt man aber 2-Faktor schon so ein bisschen aus, ne?
Weil du nicht aktiv das zweite Gerät mehr brauchst, drauf gucken musst
Ja, das als zweiten Faktor benutzt, sondern es wird halt automatisch
Das hebt doch ein bisschen 2-Faktor, ich meine das ist zwar
Naja, stell dir vor, du hast dir irgendeinen Keylogger oder irgendeinen Trojaner eingefallen, irgendwas Remote mäßiges
Ja doch, stell dir vor, du hast dir irgendeinen Trojaner eingefangen, auf deinem Rechner, gut beim Mac ein bisschen schwieriger
Irgendwie du hast ne, machen wir es mal ganz simpel, ja?
Irgendjemand ist per Team-Viewer-Session auf deinem Rechner drauf, um es mal ganz simpel zu machen
Der macht einfach deinen Browser auf, loggt sich da ein, weil du wahrscheinlich irgendein Passwort, Autofill drin hast
Dann kriegt er ne Meldung, bitte Code eingeben und es wird automatisch completed vom iPhone
Wohingegen der zweite Faktor eigentlich nicht wirklich existent war
Der zweite Faktor wäre, du musst dein iPhone nehmen, entsperren, drauf gucken was es für ein Code ist und eintippen
Das könnte der Angreifer nicht machen, oder der Team-Viewer-Session-Typ nicht machen
Es hebt schon ein bisschen 2-Faktor-Identifizierung aus
Ja, 2-Faktor im Passwort-Safe zu haben ist ja bescheuert, dann hat man keinen zweiten Faktor
Wenn man quasi das Shared-Secret im Passwort-Safe hat
Und der Passwort-Safe kann ja dann auch OTP-Tokens und so generieren
Das ist aber dann unsinnig, das ist kein zweiter Faktor mehr, das stimmt
Den 2-Faktor-Code aus
Ja, aber gerade da würdest du 2-Faktor-Identifizierung brauchen, wenn schon die Kacke am Dampfen ist
Also das weicht es ein bisschen auf, macht es natürlich deutlich bequemer
Außerdem geht sogar Copy-Paste-Hardware-übergreifend
Ich kann also einen Text oder ein Bild auf dem Rechner kopieren und ihn dann einfach auf dem iPhone einfügen
Und so geht das auch weiter, iPhones kann man ohne jegliche Identifizierung
Aber natürlich alles nur, wenn du es mit der Cloud verboten hast
iPads werden, wenn sie im gleichen Netz hängen, von macOS automatisch als Zusatz-Display vorgeschlagen
Im WLAN klappte das bei mir allerdings eher hakelig mit dem Zusatz-Display
Aber mit Kabel angeschlossen ging das super
Ja und klar, all das geht nur, wenn man voll ins Apple-Ökosystem reinspringt und halt iPhones und iPads statt Android-Geräte nutzt
Man kann das volle Potential also nur ausschöpfen, wenn man All-In geht
Cleverer Move, Apple
Positive Überraschung Nummer 3
Das kann Apple gut
Jedes Software, das ich brauche, gibt es
Ja, wirklich alles, was sich so in Jahrzehnten an Software für meinen Arbeitsalltag angesammelt hat, konnte ich problemlos unter macOS nutzen
Und das ohne irgendwelche Umgewöhnungen
Also WireGuard, Audacity, Signal, Teams, Dropbox, Firefox, Thunderbird, Photoshop etc.
Auch so etwas seltsamere Sachen wie die Steuerungssoftware für mein Studiolicht habe ich sofort gefunden
Die einzigen Kleinigkeiten, KeyPass, also das Passwort-Tool und Qubittorrent, fand ich unter macOS etwas schlechter
Sicherlich nur im Linux-Distributionen runterzuladen
Anders als unter Windows
Aber dafür gibt es dann halt schöne macOS etwas schlechter bzw. anders als unter Windows
Aber dafür gibt es dann halt schöne macOS Software, die es für Windows nicht gibt
Wie zum Beispiel die grafische Benutzeroberfläche für Whisper
Positive Überraschung Nummer 4
Die Menüleiste oben
Wie bei Windows ist die Leiste mit den Programme-Icons unten
Aber anders als bei Windows
Ja, ich finde das System mit der Leiste oben für quasi die Menüs so ein bisschen von den Anwendungen oder Leistungen
Ich finde das eigentlich eine ganz coole Sache
Ich mochte das früher auch unter Linux zu GNOME 2 Zeiten
Gab es das nämlich noch
Und ich fand das eigentlich immer ganz cool
Natürlich kann man sagen, ja, man hat ja mehr horizontalen Platz als vertikalen Platz
Dementsprechend ist das halt doof, wenn es hier oben und unten ein bisschen was wegnimmt
Ich fand das aber eigentlich usability-technisch ganz nice
Bei Windows gibt es bei macOS oben noch die sogenannte Menüleiste
Die zeigt dann links oldschool die Menüs des gerade aktiven Programms an
Aber rechts ist noch so etwas wie der Infobereich, der bei Windows unten rechts ist
Also zum Beispiel Uhrzeit und Datum
Aber halt auch WLAN, Bluetooth etc.
Wie bei Windows
Was aber nicer ist als bei Windows
Ich sehe da oben zum Beispiel direkt, ob WireGuard gerade aktiv ist oder nicht
Wenn nicht, ist es ausgegraut, sonst schwarz
Bei Windows muss ich WireGuard erst anklicken
Okay, das ist eine Kleinigkeit, aber erleichtert mir definitiv die tägliche Arbeit
Es ist auch mehr Platz für die ganzen Quick-Icons da oben rechts bei macOS
Bei Windows ist das erstmal per Default verkleinert, weil es sich eben den Platz mit der Taskleiste unten teilt
Oben bei macOS ist mehr Platz
So, jetzt das Negative
Negative Überraschung Nummer 1
Ganz ehrlich, mich macht das Fenstermanagement von macOS wahnsinnig
Verstehe ich, verstehe ich komplett
Vor allem als jemand, der Tiling-Window-Manager mag, finde ich es auch immer grausam
Und ich mag auch diese Animationen an allen Ecken nicht unter macOS
Auch wenn man das sicherlich ausschalten kann
Ich bin bei Windows dran gewöhnt, dass ich einfach unten rechts auf dieses kleine Feld hier klicke
Und dann werden alle Fenster minimiert
Oder Windows-D
Wenn ich dann wieder zu einem Programm zurück will, drücke ich Alt-Tab und cycle da so durch, bis das gewünschte Programm wieder aufgeht
Das geht bei macOS so nicht
Ich kann natürlich Fenster minimieren
Ahja, es gibt jetzt...
Warum gibt es eigentlich Windows-Tab und Alt-Tab?
Was ist da der Sinn?
Warum gibt es nicht einfach das gleiche zweimal?
Aber wenn ich da mit Command-Tab da wieder hin will
Wollen wir mal nicht so hinterfragen
Dann geht das nicht
In der Programmanzeige werden minimierte Programme zwar angezeigt, aber es passiert nichts, wenn ich da draufgehe
Außerdem funktioniert diese Snap-Funktion nicht, die ich bei Windows lieben gelernt habe
Einfach ein Fenster an die Seite und zack wird das fein säuberlich auf eine Bildschirmhälfte hochgezogen
Bei macOS kann man länger auf dieses grüne Icon hier klicken und ein Fenster auf linker Bildschirmseite anordnen
Aber das ist umständlicher
Und außerdem kann Windows auch 4 oder sogar 6 teilen
Das geht mit macOS mit Bordmitteln nicht
Allerdings gibt es dafür Zusatzsoftware für macOS fürs Snappen
Zum Beispiel Magnet, Rectangle oder Beta-Snap-Tool
Letzteres benutze ich, das kommt aus Deutschland und macht was es soll
Kostet aber alles ein paar Euro
Umsonst und umsonst ist iTab
Das versucht, könnt ihr euch bei dem Namen schon denken, das iTab-Verhalten von Windows nachzubilden
Generell ist es aber am Ende eines Arbeitstags grundsätzlich so, dass mein macOS-Desktop vollgeflastert ist mit offenen Programmen
Guck, ich mag diese Animation nicht
Es sieht zwar cool aus, aber mich nervt das
Ich will klicken und es soll sofort was passieren
Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass man diese Animation hier ausschalten kann, wenn man will
Und das nervt mich irgendwie ein bisschen
Negative Überraschung Nummer 2
Kann macOS Wobbly Windows
Das wäre für mich ja sogar noch ein Vorteil, mal Mac mir mehr anzugucken
Gibt es Wobbly Windows?
Aha, Jello
Oh, beste
Jawoll
Das ist das Erste, was ich unter Mac installieren würde
Wobbly Windows
Einfach das Geilste, was sie je erfunden haben
Leider wird Compitz auch nicht mehr weiterentwickelt
RAM-Installationen sind irgendwie nicht so gut
Lädt man Software aus dem Netz, ist die Installation erstmal angenehm simpel
Meist handelt sich das um so genannte DMGs
Genau, man track und drop das auch so den Installer
Genau, das muss man jetzt so reinziehen, das Icon
Ja, dann kann man einfach das Programm in den Programmeordner ziehen und das war's
Aktiviert man die Anzeige aller Dateiendungen
Das geht im Finder unter Einstellung erweitert
Sieht man, dass Programme einfach wirklich .app Dateien sind
Die klickt man an und dann starten die
Ja, nice
Zum Deinstallieren dann einfach die .app Datei auf den Papierkorb und fertig
Oder doch nicht fertig?
Denn es gibt auf der Platte noch einen Ordner namens Library
Und da sind etliche Dateien drin
Viele installierte Programme legen da auch was rein
Beispielsweise irgendwelche Konfigurationsdateien oder Bibliotheken oder sonst was
Unter anderem hier ein Application Support
Da sind zum Beispiel Sachen von Audacity drin
36 Megabyte
Obwohl ich das Programm gerade gelöscht habe
Die müsste man eigentlich manuell löschen
Aber dafür muss man das ganze Zeug erstmal finden
Was bei den ganzen Ordnern hier ziemlich umständlich ist
Einige Programme wie die von Adobe bringen ein eigenes Uninstall Tool mit
Das löscht hoffentlich alles
Aber wenn man ansonsten das System sauber halten will
Braucht man Zusatztools
Und das erinnert mich an längst vergangene Windows Zeiten
Denn inzwischen ist sowas deutlich mehr nötig
Denn Windows hat ein eingebautes Tool
Das Programme ziemlich rückstandsfrei entfernt
Die optionalen macOS Säuberungstools
Machen zwar vermutlich meist was sie sollen
Aber man findet im Netz auch viele Menschen
Die sich damit ihr System kaputt gemacht haben
Also das müsste doch besser gehen mit Bordmitteln in Apple oder?
Zumindest Software die man über den App Store installiert
Die kriegt man einigermaßen rückstandsfrei deinstalliert
Automatisch
Vermutlich ist das auch so ein kleiner Schubs von Apple
Um die Leute so Richtung App Store zu schieben
Machbar gefällig App Store
Bei der Software die ich installieren wollte
Habe ich nur so circa 1 Drittel im App Store gefunden
Die anderen Sachen habe ich nochmal aus dem Netz ziehen müssen
Ja wahrscheinlich weil die keinen Bock haben
Geld an Apple zu bezahlen
Und allgemein ist es natürlich auch wichtig
Dass man Software außerhalb der App Store installieren kann
Weil in den App Stores kontrolliert Apple ja
Was sie da drin haben
Und ja das will man natürlich bei seinem eigenen Computer nicht
Da will man selbst die Kontrolle darüber haben
Was man da installieren darf
Ja Negativ Punkt 3
Warum muss Apple alles anders machen?
Es gibt ja eigentlich einen Tastaturstandard
An den sich eigentlich alle halten
Also alle außer Apple
Apple Computer gab es schon vor dem IBM PC
Der 1981 raus kam
Und der den de facto Tastaturstandard vorgibt
Gut gut gut gut
Aber das Add Zeichen für E-Mail Adressen
Der ist bei US Keyboards
Sowohl bei PCs als auch bei Apple
Unter Shift 2 zu finden
Auf deutschen PC Tastaturen kriegt man den mit Alt Q
Aber bei Apple
Warum auch immer mit Alt L
Und wenn man bei Apple Alt Q drückt
Dann schließt sich das
Das kann man bestimmt ummappen oder?
Das wäre auch eines der ersten Sachen die ich ummappen würde
Das aktuelle Programm
Ja das ist scheiße
Wenn du Q drückst und es schließt das Programm
Obwohl du gerade ein Ad machen wolltest
Machen die doch extra oder?
Also der Vorteil ist natürlich
Dass sich das Alt L für Ad sofort in meinen Hirn eingebrannt hat
Weil ich will ja nicht ständig Programme schließen
Dafür vertippe ich mich dann halt
Grundsätzlich wenn ich mal wieder auf Windows
Oder Linux Rechner unterwegs bin
Ja warum? Warum muss man das so machen?
Richtig seltsam finde ich auch
Dass mein MacBook keine Entferntaste hat
Die benutze ich oft
Aber auf der MacBook Tastatur
Muss ich dabei Fn Backspace drücken
Weil es eben keine extra Taste dafür gibt
Super nervig
Glücklicherweise benutze ich die zum Arbeiten
Meist eine externe Tastatur
Da erkennt macOS zumindest die dedizierte Entferntaste
Aber hier jetzt nochmal noch was doofes
Copy Paste ist nicht
Sondern Command C V
Ja da habe ich mir auch schwer getan
An gleicher Stelle angeordnete Fn Taste
Plus C und V
Hätte nutzen können
Dann würde der Unterschied gar nicht auffallen
Nee es muss die Command Taste sein
Die ist direkt neben der Lern Taste
Warum muss das anders sein?
Moritz danke für den Sub
40 Mona ist ja extrem
Hyper Sub hier
Danke für den Sub
Ich hab sogar ein Close by Accident Guard eingebaut
Ja verständlich
Was mich wirklich extrem irritiert hat
Ich wollte mal schauen wie viel Platz ich noch auf der SSD habe
Und dann bin ich halt logisch auf Speicher
In die Systemeinstellung gegangen
Ok 382 GB frei
Und irgendwann später
Hab ich dann aber zufällig das Festplatten Dienstprogramm gefunden
Und da hieß es dann
280 GB frei
Das sind über 100 GB Unterschied
Hä?
Ist das eine Mebibyte und das andere Megabyte?
Oder was ist das?
Und ja
Gartenkralle danke für den Sub
Makishi
7 Monate
Oh der Scamtrain ist am Start
Besos muss ins Wälder
Also wenn ich beide Programme gleichzeitig starte
Und die Fenster direkt nebeneinander schiebe
Zeigen sie diese sehr unterschiedlichen Werte an
Soll das so sein?
Außerdem fand ich seltsam
Wenn man mehrere Dateien markiert
Und dann mit Rechtsklick auf Informationen geht
Um zu gucken wie viel Platz die Dateien einnehmen
Also das mache ich öfter mal unter Windows
Also wie viel Platz die zusammen einnehmen
Dann öffnet macOS für jede Datei
Einfach so ein kleines
Fenster
Könnte jetzt auch noch mit der
Komplett verwirrenden Fotoverwaltung
Mit dem Fotosprogramm anfangen
Und der Unmöglichkeit Fotos vom iPhone
Einfach als JPEGs in Ordner
Zu kopieren aber ich glaube dazu
Könnte man eigentlich mal ein ganzes Video machen
Also wenn euch das interessiert
Trotz der Negativpunkte
Bin ich insgesamt wirklich positiv überrascht
Ich hatte gedacht dass ich das MacBook
Langfristig nur so als Zweitrechner
Verwenden will aber ich muss sagen
Mir macht das so viel Spaß dass ich meinen PC
Mit Windows und Linux in den letzten Monaten
Nur ein oder zweimal eingeschaltet habe
Und das auch nur für Spiele
Also ich muss mich an einiges bei macOS
Wirklich noch gewöhnen aber die
Hohe Schwupptizität und das halt
Wirklich vieles sehr elegant funktioniert
Ja das ist schon alles sehr sehr schön
Ich will mich demnächst zwar wieder zwingen
Ein anderes Betriebssystem zu nutzen
Aber womöglich mache ich das sogar
Auf Macbook denn da kommt bald
Asahi Linux Remix raus
Und das funktioniert hoffentlich besser als die
Bisherigen Asahi Linux Versionen
Oh da gibt es Linux auf Mac
Und für Apple Silicon Macs
Bin da sehr gespannt drauf vor allem wie gut
Spiele drauf laufen genau und
Abonnieren nicht vergessen
Und Newsletter und Newsletter
Newsletter abonnieren